guy savoy n'en revient pas une esplanade
qui porte son nom dans sa ville natale
pour lui c'est un immense honneur
malgré mes succès dans le monde de la
gastronomie je ne saurais vous dire à
quel point je suis touché quelle
récompense pour un seul homme des succès
dit sa voix on a connu beaucoup chef
trois étoiles au guide michelin pour
l'un de ses restaurants parisiens est
désigné pour la deuxième année
consécutive meilleure table du monde
selon la liste
un classement réputé et même s'il a
quitté nevers à l'âge de deux ans le
chef ne peut pas oublier sa ville de
naissance car l'un de ses plats
signatures la soupe d'artichaut à la
truffe noire lui rappelle son enfance
un jour il ya une quinzaine d'années ma
mère me dit mais tu sais lorsque tu
étais bébé la seule purée que manger
était la purée d'artichaut comme quoi
les premières années de la vie marques
ou marques pour bourlon pour la ville
pour le maire de nevers cette plaque
participe à la renommée de sa ville qui
savoie et à nos porteurs d'image et
l'accepter de lettres à nos ambassadeurs
jde dit tout à l'heure donc voilà il est
clair qu'en termes d'image de retomber
montrer aussi cannes au vert on a des
qualités compris gastronomique même si
on n'a pas dit sa voix complètement ça
nous permet d'avoir un peu un peu plus
tôt dans la journée le musée des
beaux-arts et de la faïence a ouvert ses
portes aux chefs et comme la cuisine
n'est jamais loin
l'oeuvre en faïence couleur bleue de
nevers lui donne des idées
je la mettrais en assiettes de
présentation
pourquoi pas sur une table de banquet
comme ça on aurait l'oeuvre parfaitement
reproduit avec cette grue guy savoy
perçoit tout de suite le symbole de
l'avenir de la construction
car avant d'être chef de quatre
restaurants à paris et d'un à las vegas
il a commencé à l'âge de 16 ans comme ce
jeune homme qu'il vient saluer en
cuisine avant de manger dans ce
restaurant de varennes vauzelles il dit
bonjour à toute l'équipe
impressionné a toujours un petit peu et
puis surtout très content ce que
les savoie fait partie des gens je pense
qu'ils représentent bien la profession
et qui transmettent toujours leur savoir
et qui sont très accessibles
le chef étoilé semble apprécier enfin
guy savoy ne peut pas rester longtemps à
nevers il doit retourner dans ses
restaurants les l'a promis il reviendra
à nevers sur l'esplanade 10 à bois